hello and welcome to this video on
playing craft soup 96 almost a possible
pre-move is playing my own repertoire
it still surprises people that move so f
3 is the most natural and some this is
of course possible doesn't look very
scary for black but it is certainly a
playable playable option okay so I don't
know let's prevent Bishop g5 maybe that
gives it a little bit more a little bit
more to play for on the other hand Jim
Knight f5 it's annoying
they will see what happens maybe I can
nade f5 is really annoying I don't like
what I did what I did Jim I'm not not in
trouble but i still dislike my plane now
yes c4 lined up which is a standard
standard ADM and I cannot lose my
McQueen or that well I can but snatcher
5
I have Queen to b4 in case of that
that's not really comfortable here I
wonder if C for now is still a move it
certainly is a man and he plays it
no I'm still reasonably active queen
takes rook c8 I mean I know I don't
think I can be in any substantial issues
every single piece and pawn that I have
is protected and somehow coordinated and
therefore it cannot be terrible I think
yeah not sure if this is the most
ambitious movement it's maybe not so bad
yeah
I mean what is he doing here Rupert III
I mean the Queen has not a good square
really where where'd she go I should
yeah now they mean the back rank is a
bit weak but might be no way to use it
yeah probably maybe I can play against
FGM
okay now anyway to invade on the second
ring
he still has tonight at five I can't
let's do that look at the pond on a two
and step out of the night at five move
with the tempo I might also have nice d5
it's not super easy for Wyatt in fact I
mean he has not he doesn't have a really
obvious move now what you should do my
bishop is a bit better you know you have
to play for little things here you
cannot mean in this opening I know why I
recommended it for white it's just like
very tough to to get into trouble that
that probably wasn't move that irritate
some it's not easy this is hanging
interesting choice M but I have a couple
of ideas now I have Queen I wanted to
say Queen to b6 but in fact that is not
such a great one this one don't looks
good attack the bishop and there are
ideas here related to Bishop f2 and
Queen f6 if I take one I have two King
takes Queen f6 check the rook is hanging
at the entity five hang so though and
it's not so nice when to Queen f6 just
like that as probably running into rope
to f1 taketake Queen f6 checking edge
two ticks on a one takes on d5 I don't
have the good news there okay maybe 2006
I don't know
it's feels a bit lame okay it's it's
still a bit of pressure
we are taking us definitely a little bit
better for black but I have to
okay so let's retreat and now I enter on
c2 f5 now is a threat it's difficult for
him now to keep the material
hmm I totally forgot that this is a
movie already okay I'm there it's still
annoying so now I can take it
I'm near this is unfortunately still
very dry King every who hunts into a
mate that's funny
check King g4 h5 checkmate so he has to
go back
this one is rook c5 that's next
unfortunate
got eight seconds left not very
comfortable
I'm not sure that was best but it's it's
easy to play at least right wasn't best
quite clearly now it's the wrong color
to them wrong bishop that's so painful
I'm not winning this is painful because
you're pressing the whole time very
stupid okay yeah I try to press water
out of stone and I got water and it
didn't didn't convert it yes so yeah
nothing much going on then like
gradually I got a little something yeah
I'm very happy with Queen e6 that is a
strong move I thought okay I didn't see
Knight g4 the engine is of course is of
course seeing things
that
I could have won a night it's in the
chat somewhere yes yeah it's not really
something that I'm surprised about and I
could have taken yeah but Dwyer
it's a chitchat it's check of course I'm
stupid I'm totally stupid I am I saw
this and somehow it didn't register that
this is Chekhov horse and so then this
is just winning off
that's stupid yeah so then this is just
so k better for black but not a win and
so at some point I could have one in my
again where was that we should be 5
check ok you have to take those chances
I mean if they blunder like no tomorrow
we should take it but of course that
sets probably still a win yeah I should
not have concentrate looks I was just
like I wanted to
yeah simplified playing but of course I
just allow the draw probably it's
probably not possible to win anymore
with the wrong Bishop and this is of
course making it super easy
yeah but probably you cannot win it's
very unlikely Niki only has to do is to
sacrifice the night against the Jeep on
and then it's the wrong color vision ok
how many chances missed thanks a lot for
watching